Transcriber: Ahmad Hammadi
المدقّق: Mohamed Salem
I am Hanan Ramsis
,I am so interested in stock exchange
training and Entrepreneurship
thank you
(applause)
of course, I am so interested in youth
because, as we say, they are the future
and the next in taking
the responsibility of development
and in every thing related to
next successes
I am so interested in Entrepreneurship
because it is not
a wide prevalent idea in Egypt
at contrast of the Arab world
because we have a problem
which is that we have
low financial abilities
but we have high ambitions
I am so interested in
changing youth’s way of thinking
and making them
invest all of their abilities
using their talents and personal vision
,so with a few resources
every one can be an Entrepreneur
Entrepreneur is a person who can manage
a project no matter what the resources are
and be a profit project
and the person take the responsibility
of this project
of course, there are a lot of people
interested in training on what they work
when they enter the labour market
there are a lot of people
who wanted to start their own projects
some people wants to work at banks
and governmental institutions
but we want to develop the idea
because we discovered that the whole world
depends on developing small projects
and increasing the ability
of country to compete
and increasing its resources
so we are very interested in
the Entrepreneurship of youth
every one can invest
in stock exchange to be an Entrepreneur
they can be a dealer in stock market
and deal in a limited amount of money
and understand the way of trading
because trading is a strategy
depends on studying not luck
,after starting trading, success
and making a good amount of money
I can begin my own project in cooperation
with friends who are the same of me
and have the same wish of success
so we register our project
in stock exchange
through Nile stock exchange
for small and medium projects
this may qualifies me to share
my successful experience with others
to enable them follow the same steps
I am also interested in
enhancing youth’s edification
to make them start writing
their economic ideas
which they learned and studied
in university, for example
post them on websites
and give youth the chance
to contribute with us by their opinion
in country’s knotty economic issues
we must give them a chance
when youth has their own channel
in which they can achieve their ambition
then they will have the ability
to continue and create
and has the ability to study hard
and define their country’s problems
find the best solution for them
,we can, as a government
invest the youth who has new ideas
to solve intractable problems
whom we could not solve in the past
beside that
we can encourage them, if they have
,a good knowledge about trading
create a channel on YouTube to explain
the way of trading for starters
for example, how they can
create an individual project
all of these are common ideas between us
but every one of us needs to know
the best way to achieve his/her ambitions
of course, when government nears distances
between education and labour market
this is what we interested in
at the current period
we will see at the next period
a lot of people who have good ideas
that can save the government
from successive economic crises
that’s it
(applause)
thank you